okay now I gave us this example just now
because it was one that you already knew
the answer to so you could confirm that
it worked okay but let's now imagine
here let's go to that ridiculous you
know situation before where I said let's
just put like a ridiculous power in here
okay and we'll start it from scratch
you've got y equals now let's make that
let's make it 30 okay this is completely
impractical to expand okay but I can
approach this with the same tool that I
used here okay if I let you and I'm
gonna stop saying use a function of X
because I wrote that to clarify to you
what was going on it's not just another
variable it's a function but I don't
need to write it any more than I need to
write that and Y as a function of X let
u equal that thing on the inside okay in
fact politically it's often called the
inside function right that's on the
inside and on the outside it's getting
raised to the power of 30 let u equal
that function so now I can differentiate
that inside function with respect to X
because that's the variable I'm talking
about it's still 8x just like it was
before because this inside function and
that inside function I have not altered
okay but now because of this
substitution I can say Y is going to be
that inside function raised to the power
of a and this is trivially simple to
differentiate just like that one goes
right dy on D u because it's a different
variable it's just bring the power down
and reduce the power by one that's it
all you need to do and now comes in
chain rule I want to string these two
derivatives this guy and this guy
I want to chain them together to produce
the actual derivative that I want cuz
these are just means to an end right do
you want to DX I'm gonna pull out this
line again because we just started is dy
u times du you
on DX now I'm just going to say quickly
a bit of a note I write this over and
over again even though it seems like
it's going to be the same every time as
we will see as we go further and further
into calculus and you remember I alluded
to before if you have so like the volume
of a cylinder okay it's got a radius and
it's got its higher you're going to be
learning to differentiate with respect
to different things and combining them
in different ways these letters up here
they are going to change their orders
are going to change their places are
going to change so I like getting into
the habit of not skipping this step so I
know exactly what variables I'm dealing
with okay
it seems true that the moment cuz what
other variables are there but you will
soon learn there will be more okay I'm
gonna pull my results in okay I'm gonna
write this line 30 I'm not gonna write
you because I know what you is actually
equal to because I introduced the
substitution myself 4x squared plus 129
and then I've got my D you on DX hang on
the end 8 by 30
as easy as tying your shoelaces okay now
a few things to note on this process
it's gonna take a lot to get familiar
with it because it's kind of like you
know your brain is expanding but any all
these extra repertoire you know sort of
extra skills in your repertoire and so I
really highly recommend you do these
steps to clarify where all of this
business comes from okay but as you
proceed through I mean if I were doing
this question and I went teaching it to
you from this line that line right there
the question I would jump in I would
jump in right there okay and the reason
why is because once you become familiar
you see up this is clearly a function of
our function so number one I've
identified what it is so I know what
rule I want to apply it through you know
established it so now I can just use it
okay and then I see like you remember
how I said this inside and outside right
that's a cloaking way of saying I just
need to differentiate the inside there
is and then I just need to differentiate
the outside to the inside to the outside
if you don't like that kind of thing
it's multiplication so you can just as
easily do the outside and the inside the
you order doesn't matter here okay but
the keys you need to do both right the
easiest thing is just to forget to do
one of them okay and there it is there's
one and there's the other
I have to go directly to this line and
then use put it together just to
simplify algebraically that's all there
is to it okay now I want to emphasize
okay I've gotten to this point after
years right so I'm this is why I plead
on the board I highly recommend all of
these desk particularly well it is the
first time you've met it okay so make
really clear what you're doing you're
doing a substitution okay later on like
I said when we have different variables
actually flying around even the very
best of you can really really really
confident even me who I could go to this
line straight away I'm actually gonna
say I know what my substitution is I've
got a different chair on its own and
then I'll have this you're gonna have so
many
functions flying around you know in the
same question you really can't afford to
just confuse yourself right so I won't
always go directly to this line but if
this is the question you will get to a
point where you're comfortable you can
just jump straight it questions yeah yes
yes it is so by the way let's just let's
just think for a second on this function
what does that function like no idea
okay let's see I think it's gonna look
something like it's plus one I guess it
would look like this that's a bit late
but anyway um I know because gonna be
plus one and then it's just gonna be
really really state because of this um
yes it's yeah it's gonna be so you you
think about this this component which is
shifted up by one and then when you
raise it to these powers I mean one has
that curious thing that like zero no
matter what how you raise one two it
will still be one so that was just by
coincidence okay um but then it's just
really really steep that's all this does
just make it really really steep uh yeah
that's true
that's true but if you rewrite it if we
were to do and you can see it in this
line if I were to go ahead and expand
can you see this one which is the same
as this one really it's always going to
expand out to one no matter how big it's
really actually modifying this guy do
you see that like it's not obvious but
it's really Y minus one that's actually
less to do with the accident has to do
with the line so that would be the shape
now what is this thing this is this is
going to be another or form or
polynomial without doing any expansion
you know what its degree is actually
going to be don't you what was the
degree of this one
what's the degree of this moment it's
for its for because it comes from - the
- if this was - and this was a three
it'll be six that's right because when
you have a power of a power it's like a
function of function you multiply those
powers together so this is going to be ^
yep 59 you get 58 from here and then you
get the 59th from there right which
makes sense because this one is to the
power 60 right
every time you differentiate because of
the whole way that differentiation works
you're losing a power you lose a power
decomposers down that way just like you
know the derivative of x cubed goes to x
squared right scribe goes that's a
linear function and so on